[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais enregistrer votre mariage
suivant les lois de notre pays un pays
libre invincible et indépendants - lysia
je te prends pour marie je te jure amour
et fidélité jusqu'à la mort dans cette
guerre il n'y a qu'un seul responsable
c'est de l'avenir poutine
après avoir menti au monde entier et fin
la voie de la diplomatie
il a renié tous les engagements
internationaux de la russie
il a fait le choix de la guerre un
moment émouvant pour les soldats
fleur au bout du fusil pour valérie
pellisier je viens d'être informé qu'il
y à une attaque de huit roquettes sur
vinnytsia notre ville pacifique qui n'a
jamais représenté une menace pour la
russie c'est une frappe rude et cynique
l'aéroport a été détruit la résistance
s'affiche partout dans la ville
les messages de propagande ont remplacé
les publicités les habitants manifestent
un au péril de leur vie car la loi
martiale elle est instaurée dans les
villes occupées par les russes il est
interdit de se réunir à plus de trois
personnes je lui demanderais avec force
de mettre en place ce cessez le feu pour
arrêter cette pluie de bombes qui
tombent sur le peuple ukrainien et au
moins je demanderai un cessez le feu
humanitaire
de son côté joe biden s'est adressé
directement au peuple russe par twitter
disant je suis persuadé que vous ne
voulez pas d'une guerre sanglante et
destructrice avec le crâne avec qui vous
avez tant de liens disant aussi aux
citoyens russes vous n'êtes pas nos
ennemis nous portons un message à cet
instant stop à la guerre stop à
l'invasion de l'ukraine
un label qui envahit ukraine et russes
aussi en font les frais maj de cette
vidéo impressionnante un hélicoptère
russe abattu par un missile antiaérien
moscou demande à l'union européenne et
l'otan d'arrêter immédiatement les
livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine par cette
base en pologne que transitent les
livraisons promises à l'armée
ukrainienne par une vingtaine de pays
occidentaux et lance roquettes anti
chars des missiles anti aériens des
fusils d'assaut des munitions il faut
que le débat se puisse se conduire et
que moi aussi en tant que candidat aussi
je puisse expliquer convaincre proposé
être attaqué critiqué
contesté répondre à la controverse n'est
pas possible de filmer ni de nous parler
ici ok donc on doit partir oui
impossible donc de savoir précisément ce
qu'il y a dans ces conteneurs
transportés par six camions de l'armée
française j'entends que la vidéo est
critiqué j'entends qu'on dit il utilise
son compte twitter mais qu'est ce que
font les autres candidats ils ont des
fonctions madame taubira elle a tout
compris et s'est retiré discrètement
entre deux obus russe et une alerte
nucléaire anne hidalgo aurait pu faire
la même chose mais elle est dans un tel
élan qu'elle s'est dit que ce serait
quand même dommage de renoncer il faut
jouer si je puis dire le premier tour
que les français fassent leur choix et
sur croyances bilan sur le sujet vous le
savez comme vous le savez il ya une
finale si je puis dire du débat yannick
jadot lui au voilier a profité de
l'occasion pour se débarrasser de
sandrine rousseau dit vu ni connu jamais
eu en prison de la république qui a
débattu avec d'autres candidats au
premier tour dans notre sélection que
j'ai regardé à la télévision qu'il
reconnaissait un vous peut-être que les
temps changent c'est une autre question
comme ses concurrents il participera à
des émissions de télévision et répondra
aux questions des journalistes et
éditorialistes peut-être de politique on
verra les propositions qui seront faites
par les chaînes de télévision marion
maréchal a tourné le dos à sa tante
marine le pen pour rejoindre
officiellement eric zemmour elle était
sur scène cet après midi lors du meeting
du candidat de reconquête à toulon dans
le var